just about everywhere in the valley you
go you see homeless people there are
more than 5 000 individuals in southern
Nevada who are homeless right now
according to help home Foundation which
focuses on ending homelessness as Mary
Jane belly as a reports there was an
increase of close to 600 homeless in
just 2021 alone
homeless Advocates tell me there are a
number of issues that contribute to
homelessness including unemployment
substance abuse issues and mental health
issues Lakeisha Oliver is a clinician
from Solutions of change a mental health
service we recognize again that the
connection between homelessness and
mental health concerns is not always
black and white we have to see each
individual and what their needs are
based on their specific circumstance
it's a concern following the latest
stabbing on the Strip Yani Barrios found
himself homeless and wandering the strip
the Clark County district attorney says
mental competency might play a role
during his trial Kristen avalis is the
director of client services at hopelink
a non-profit organization preventing
homelessness through Rapid housing we do
get hundreds of calls a day of people
looking for rental assistance or
emergency shelter per day we tried to
take 50 per day for rental assistance we
try to take we have a waiting list
usually for emergency shelter I think we
currently have about 50 people 50
families and our program Avila says she
has seen a mix of homeless nevadans and
transplants come through their doors she
says many people who need help don't
know the resources available and many
agencies are at capacity because of the
high demand between inflation high rent
and unemployment she anticipates more
people to be homeless both Solutions of
change and hope link are trying to
bridge the gap when it comes to those
disparities Mary Jane valleza 8 News Now
services at Solutions of change are free
of charge available to anyone in the
community we do have more information on
this nonprofit as well as many other
agencies helping the homeless on our
website at 8newsnow.com